Hamza from hamza's Den is the Simone
biles of mental gymnastics let's take a
look at his floor routine on the Islamic
dilemma the Islamic dilemma is an
argument that can take many forms but in
its most basic form it goes something
like this the Quran affirms the
inspiration preservation and authority
of the Jewish and Christian scriptures
but the Quran contradicts the Jewish and
Christian scriptures on fundamental
doctr
now there are only two possibilities
here either Jews and Christians have the
inspired preserved authoritative word of
God or we don't it's one or the other on
one horn of the Dilemma if we have the
inspired preserved authoritative word of
God Islam is false because Islam
contradicts what we have on the other
Horn of the Dilemma if we don't have the
inspired preserved author ative word of
God Islam is false because Islam affirms
the inspiration preservation and
authority of what we have so if we have
the reliable and authoritative word of
God Islam is false if we don't have the
reliable and authoritative word of God
Islam is false either way Islam is false
therefore Islam is
false how do daag gists respond to this
airtight argument the same way they
respond to every argument
smoke and mirrors Hamza posted a short
that's supposed to refute the Islamic
dilemma let's watch Hamza completely
contradict his own God his own prophet
and his own
books my man here yeah he's claimed that
Muhammad must upon him attested the
veracity and the truthfulness of the
inel I also claim that Muhammad affirmed
the injil injil is the Arabic word for
gospel it's a transliteration of the
Greek word yelan meaning gospel Muhammad
affirmed the inil so did Allah Muhammad
upon him attested the veracity and the
truthfulness of the inel which he did
yeah the inil he did he did yeah he did
Muhammad did attest the veracity and the
truthfulness of the injil and so did
Allah we agree Christians and Muslims
agree on this but our dawa friends know
all to well that the inil we have
contradicts the Quran on Jesus death
resurrection and divine nature so
they're going to have to claim that the
inil is something we don't
have then who are you just what's the
the New Testament is not the you tell me
what's theil not the New Testament what
is the meaning of inil what's the inil
good question if it's not the gospel
that Christians have because what we
have contradicts the Quran
what is it what is the Islamic concept
of in so that's what I'm asking you
you're the Muslim you tell me what's the
Islamic concept of concept so what is
the book going to I'm going to explain
so the Quran makes it clear inil is a
book that was given to Jesus from God
what does the Quran make clear so the
Quran makes it clear in is a book that
was given to Jesus from God what's the
inil theil is a book that was given to
Jesus from God one more time the inil is
a book that was given to Jesus from God
the inil is a book that was given to
Jesus from God so that's the definition
they're going with and this idea is
based on Surah 5 verse 46 of the Quran
which we'll read in a few moments but
let's allow our dawa friends to finish
their point are you a Christian yes do
you believe Jesus received a book from
God Allah called the inil no we agre
with you that you don't believe in theil
there you have it folks Muhammad and the
Quran affirm the injil but the inil
isn't what Christians have in the New
Testament instead it's a book given to
Jesus from God and we don't have a book
given to Jesus from God hence we don't
have the inal we don't have it
Christians have never had a book that
was given to Jesus from God so we've
never had the inal poor Christians
dawa fans watch hamza's clip and say
alhamdulillah such a powerful response
the Christians have been
humiliated but there's a problem with
hamza's claim that Christians don't have
the injil Allah and Muhammad say very
clearly that we do have the inal
consider a few passages Surah 7 verse
157 of the Quran refers to those who
follow the messenger Muslims believe the
messenger here is Muhammad those who
follow the messenger the unlettered
prophet whom they find inscribed in the
Torah and the gospel that is with them
gospel here in Arabic is inil the Quran
says that Jews and Christians find
Muhammad inscribed in the Torah and the
gospel that are with us what's the injil
according to our daa friends
theil is a book that was given to Jesus
from God so if the inil is a book given
to Jesus from God and the Quran says
that we find Muhammad inscribed in the
injil that's with us the Quran is
claiming that we have a book that was
given to Jesus from God right Hamza and
his friend say we don't have the inil
Allah says we do and hamza's fans will
believe him even when he contradicts
Allah isn't that that
amazing now we'll take a closer look at
the verse that says the inil is a book
given to Jesus but we'll also read the
verse that comes right after it Sora 5:
46 and
47 and in their footsteps we sent Jesus
Son of Mary confirming the Torah that
had come before him and we gave him the
gospel wherein is a guidance and a light
confirming the Torah that had come
before him as a guidance and an
exhortation to the reverent our dawa
friends insist that this means the injil
is a book given to Jesus from God but
here's the next verse let the people of
the Gospel judge by what God has sent
down therein whosoever judges not by
that which God has sent down it is they
who are
iniquitous the Quran claims that Allah
is perfectly clear in his commands and
here Christians have a command from
Allah we have to judge by what Allah
sent down in the gospel the inal if we
don't we're
iniquitous what are we supposed to judge
by the
inal what are we if we don't judge by
the
inil we're
iniquitous do we have the inal
according to Hamza and daag gists
everywhere we don't we don't have the
injil Allah orders us to judge by a book
that we don't have and he says we're
evil if we don't judge by a book that we
don't have do you see what the daag have
done Allah says we have the injil we
supposedly find Muhammad mentioned in
the injil that we have Allah orders us
to judg by the inil in the same passage
that Hamza and his friend used to claim
that we don't have the inil does it make
any sense any sense at all for Allah to
command us to judge by a book that we
don't have after he says that we do have
it and that we find Muhammad mentioned
in
it absolutely none whatsoever but it's
what the daag guys claim they claim that
Allah's command is total
nonsense but it's not just Allah in Jam
ter 2653 hamza's Prophet declares the
Torah and injil are with the Jews and
Christians but what do they Avail of
them Muhammad says that the inil is with
the Christians what's the inil according
to our dawa friends the inil is a book
that was given to Jesus from God so
Muhammad says that a book that was given
to Jesus from God is with with the
Christians he says the inil is with the
Christians do you see the problem here
and do you see why the daag don't deal
with the real issue Allah says
Christians have the injil Muhammad says
Christians have the injil daag gands say
no Allah and Muhammad are wrong fine
Allah and Muhammad are wrong but if
you're claiming that Allah and Muhammad
are wrong why are you calling yourselves
Muslim
when Muslims are people who submit to
Allah and
Muhammad make it make sense
Hamza you can't because it doesn't make
sense Allah said that he gave the injil
to Jesus you pretend deceptively that
this is the only thing Allah ever said
about the injil it wasn't Allah also
said that we have the inil and that we
have to judge by the injil and Allah's
Prophet Muhammad said we have the injil
so Hamza if you're right and we don't
have the injil then Allah and Muhammad
are
wrong congratulations Hamza you and your
friend and all your fans who celebrated
your response are apostates now
according to Muhammad not according to
me according to Muhammad if a man
contradicts Allah and people listen to
the man instead of to Allah they're
worshiping that man
you contradict Allah Hamza so when your
followers listen to you and not to Allah
your followers are worshiping
you welcome to dawa ladies and gentlemen
dawa is a cult of men setting themselves
up as Idols to replace Allah and when it
comes to the mental gymnastics they have
to do they all get the gold of course
you may be thinking to yourself well
even if those pass sound like they're
affirming the gospel that Christians
have perhaps there are other passages
that say Christians don't have the
gospel if you're thinking something like
that be sure to watch my video what the
Quran really says about the gospel where
I go through every single verse in the
Quran that so much as mentions the injil
if you think hams is right check out the
video and explain to me why there isn't
a single verse anywhere in thean
that's even slightly critical of the
Gospel that Christians have
[Music]